Fold up your Grillo portable BBQ.
And safely pack your post apocalyptic food
in a Tactical Lunch Box.
Because it's episode 41 of LÜT.
Improve your skills on the court with the
94 fifty smart basketball. It measures everything
from ball handling and shot accuracy to shot
speed and spin acceleration and the information
is updated from ball to app in 100 milliseconds.
Get ready for summer from the inside out with
an Anatomical bathing suit.
And while you're at the beach watch for a
whale..... bottle opener.
To crack open a drink and pour into a cup
that is floating in a palm tree drink raft.
Kept cold with your ground cooler. The e-cool
is a year round drink cooler that doesn't
use electricity because it uses THE EARTH.
Trust your gut and make an executive decision
with your morning coffee.
Like the decision to eat chocolate sausage
that might come with its own chopping board
and knife but doesn't come with a nose spoon.
Continue to play with your senses using aroma
forks. There are 21 aromas to choose from
so you can mix and match to trick your palette
into believing you're eating almost anything.
If you can't make it taste like bacon, just
wear it on this charm bracelet.
Then get your fortune and a sugar high with
fortune-telling cupcake liners and match your
mood with these roll on perfumes.
For those who chose play make sure to get
a slide rider. That turns your stairs into
slide and and I mean what else can I say it
turn your stairs into a slide!
Use Otto to capture your happy slide face
and turn it into an animated GIF (or gif).
It's a hackable customizable digital camera
that automatically shares the photos with
your smart phone.
Next show off your Google glass.
Because you're so rich you can make it rain
confetti.
Make just about anything with the M3D. The
first consumer 3D printer can be used by beginners.
It's now available for pre-order and will
fit nicely next to your butt station desk
accessory.
Get off your butt and fly a paper airplane
with a smartphone. The Power Up 3.0 has a
180 foot range and flies for ten minutes per
charge. Once you fold and attach just connect
to your phone and fly away from a...
TERRIFYING MASK OF YOUR OWN FACE!
Calm down and listen to something slow in
these custom slug headphones all while you
snuggle up with a classic book pillow.
Play with a new spin on a classic using smart
mass thinking putty. Which comes in styles
ranging from unicorn tears to magnetic giant
lizard green.
Then thumbs down your friends in the Thumb
Wrestling Arena.
And take your pet fish for a walk with the
help of fish on wheels, that let's the fish
do the steering by detecting the direction
that it's swimming.
Finally, after all that I must say that "I'm
glad you're as weird as me".... greeting cards
And as always...thanks for watching.